nein lewis hamilton ist noch nicht
wieder formel 1 weltmeister aber ja
lewis hamilton hat den großen preis von
mexiko wurden hier an diesem
sonntagnachmittag in mexiko-stadt und er
hat diesen großen preis gewonnen ohne
dass man vorher unbedingt damit rechnen
konnte andere waren in einer viel
besseren ausgangsposition ferrari zum
beispiel in der ersten startreihe
schwelle klären neben sebastian vettel
aber mercedes hatte die bessere
strategie aber bereit mehr risiko
einzugehen hatte im rennen gemerkt dass
die reifen weit weniger stark abbauen
als das vorher erwartet worden war
geklärt wurde zweimal an die box gerufen
und war damit aus dem kreis der
siegfahrer ausgeschieden fette kamen
wohl etwas zu spät zum ersten und
einzigen mal an die box da war hamilton
schon längst dort gewesen der vor dann
am ende
47 runden mit einem satz reifen und
ungefährdet ins ziel
zum sieg vettel wurde zweiter
team-kollege weitere potters im zweiten
mercedes wurde dritter und hielt so
seine minimale wm chance noch ein wenig
am leben hamilton reichen jetzt vier
punkte aus den letzten drei rennen um
zum sechsten mal weltmeister zu werden
und dieses rennen hier in mexiko hat
eben gezeigt warum erzählt es nach wie
vor die referenz ist wenn es darum geht
wer in der formel 1 den ton angibt wie
gesagt ferrari hat ein wenig die die
strategie zu risikolos gestaltet red
bull wiederum die eigentlich das
schnellste auto hatten marx verstappen
war ja die schnellste runde gefahren im
qualifying wurde dann zurückgestuft um
drei positionen weil er bei gelb
geschenkter flagge nicht verlangsamt
hatte red bull wäre eigentlich auch
konkurrenzfähig gewesen in diesem rennen
aber fest tappen in der von ihm kann
wollte es mit der brechstange versuchen
schon in den ersten kurven kollidiert
dabei leicht mit hamilton der
anschließend ziemlich frank und frei in
der pressekonferenz sagte
mit vettels zustimmung dass das ist
schon so sei dass man insbesondere fest
tappen immer schon extra viel platz
einräumen weil man
wisse wie aggressiv der zu werke geht
und ja heute hat das für festplatten
nicht gereicht er ist erst mit hamilton
kollidiert hat sich dann noch einen
plattfuß angefangen als er wenig später
beim versuch wieder weiter nach vorne zu
kommen
ein wenig mit vaughters pochierte damit
war das rennen gelaufen was für ihn drin
gewesen wäre zeigt die tatsache dass er
danach vom letzten bis auf den sechsten
platz wieder vor gefahren ist aber
nichtsdestotrotz schlussendlich hatte
mercedes hier gewonnen und damit belegt
dass sie nach wie vor die nummer eins
sind in der formel 1